anime has given us a lot of emotions
joy excitement sadness anger the list
goes on i've talked about some of the
top moments in anime but i found out
that i've yet to make a compilation of
the most satisfying moments in anime yet
these moments are probably not the most
hyped ones in the respected series that
are chock full of epic scenes but a lot
of them can be contenders so
i digress so for today i'll be counting
down the top 10 most
satisfying moments in anime it can be
the culmination of a training arc the
finale of a moment that's been long
built up
a villain who gets what's coming to him
or the redemption of a plucky character
who you can't help but cheer for
basically it's a compilation of moments
that gave some of the biggest payoffs in
anime
we start off with a surprisingly tame
moment in bleach at first glance
ichigo tossing eisen
when we think bleach we think magical
swords over the top powers
and reality warping stuff it didn't take
too long for shonen anime standards to
reach that point in bleach but this
moment is surprisingly tame in relation
because what we have here is no getsu
gatencho no super kiddo display
just playing ichigo grabbing eisen and
tossing him away from karakura town
leading up to this moment we've always
seen eisen in one mood
calm and in control he's been the poster
boy for chess master villains and shown
an anime at bleach's peak and he always
seems so
calculated and methodical with his plans
there's no way to rattle his plans
to the point where his knowledge and
planning of everything about our hero
has become a meme
in the end it feels amazing to see him
finally be rattled and lose it even for
that brief instant
after all that condescending talking
about ichigo being weaker
it was a surreal sight to see eisen
finally face someone
that he couldn't just walk over smugly
following ichigo we have naruto taking
the stage for getting recognized after
the pain arc
it's been a long time coming and it's
one of the most satisfying and rewarding
moments in the entire naruto series for
so long naruto has been the underdog
starting off as the noisy annoying kid
who dreamt of becoming hokage naruto is
not exactly endeared himself to a lot of
people
along the way he found no shortage of
rivals was always a step behind his own
teammate sasuke and just seemed to be
delusional
becoming holgangi was nothing but a pipe
dream for this dreamer nonetheless he
persevered and he never gave up on his
dream at this point in the story
the dream of becoming hakagi or getting
recognized by the village
had been put aside in favor of training
in order to stop pain and protect the
village
let's just say that he came back looking
nothing short of a hero it was a
glorious entrance to save
everyone and finally face off against
payne in a decisive battle
brandishing his newly attained sage form
naruto was able to come out on top and
fight pain off the most cathartic part
of this is what happens afterwards
though
it's amazing to see him being showered
with love and finally becoming
everyone's hero
to take that haters we've come such a
long way and the hyperactive outcast has
finally become a hero
[Applause]
tv
next is takamura's rage against hawk the
whole arc with hawk is just one big
redemption tour for takamura
on second thought i think i've used
redemption to all wrong what is there to
redeem when takamura is already one of
the most awesome characters from hajime
no ippo
at that point in the story nevertheless
the arc just showcased the amount of
struggle thakamura had to go through in
order to chase his dreams
of conquering multiple weight classes
not making the first step on his journey
easy is his opponent
brian hawke the wbc junior middleweight
champion spends most of the arc in the
build-up to the eventual fight being a
thorn in the side of takamura first
showcasing his mettle against dakomula
in pre-fight confrontations before
acting all cocky in the lead-up to the
fight
this is a man that's continuously mocked
him and belittled all his efforts to
make it to the bout
seeing takamura just unleash his rage on
his opponent as well as the resulting
beatdown just feels so satisfying the
fight especially from this moment on is
just one of the best moments in ippo
and it gave me goosebumps to see
takamura finally get his one up on hall
[Music]
adaptation territory sword art online's
war of underworld gave us
gabrielle miller's death for most of war
of underworld we've been told to hate
this villain
it's no secret that sao villains are
almost always hate cigs but i doubt that
anyone can match gabriel miller in terms
of just sheer evil while the other guys
are just mostly memes that sexually
assault women we have here an actual
mass
murderer and a sociopath hiding
underneath a cold
calm facade you wouldn't expect that
this guy hired by the americans to steal
japanese research would have a
destructive fascination with the human
soul to the point of murdering his
childhood friend just to see her soul
the guy dying to kirito's attack that
was powered by the souls of literally
everyone in underworld was satisfying
enough but what comes next
is even better waking up as a ghost
after having physically died he finds
himself reunited with the childhood
friend that he murdered the upbeat
reunion would quickly turn ugly though
and he finally finds himself getting
dragged off to hell by none other than
the thousands of people that he killed
just for his sick
enjoyment it's a really scary way to go
but one that someone liked him deserved
yoshigangigira would be proud
in a somewhat similar scenario to the
last one we have yet another villain
being punished for his sins in maltese
punishment in
shield hero i don't know if malty's
worse than gabrielle miller but i'm
fairly certain about one thing
she feels more real and relevant i bet
that most of you probably don't know a
sociopathic mass murderer who desires to
look at people's souls and if you do
well i guess you better be careful in
contrast mind or malty just feels more
real
manipulative people are everywhere and
fake accusations abound in this chaotic
world which is why i feel slightly more
cathartic to see her final judgment and
punishment in the last few episodes of
shield hero
after putting naofumi through hell and
kick-starting his quest for revenge it
feels extra satisfying to see her
finally get her comeuppance now i saw a
lot of people calling for her head in
this scene and seeing her beg for mercy
was all sorts of pathetic
very fitting for a character like her i
think sure she didn't get killed off due
to nail fumi's intervention but having
to live on with her new
unflattering name and having to live
with the fact that everyone knows you're
a liar can be a fate worse than death
hey at least she still has a mordred
look-alike simping over her so that's
something right
[Music]
moving on we take a look at tokyo ghoul
with a moment courtesy of kaneki
doesn't it just feel so cool to see the
me kid get pushed around until he snaps
in such a chilling way
well not the pushing around part
obviously but there's really a thing
about revenge plots that keep people
coming
tokyo ghoul's not a revenge plot but
when kaneki finally snaps at jason and
accepts his ghoul powers it was a sight
to see
for so long garneki had been trying to
run away from his identity and his
powers
accepting the fact that he'd become a
part of ghoul society wasn't easy and
more so was the truth that he'd become a
monster with those violent powers
after a series of torture at the hands
of jason he finally loses it basically
he says that's enough
and hands jason a beat down like we've
never seen in tokyo ghoul the op
playing and garniki suddenly taking an
edgy language was simply the perfect
finale for tokyo ghoul it's a landmark
moment that forever changed the
landscape of the series and it gave
garniki the much needed big win to close
out the first season
[Applause]
number four on our list is a trademark
luffy moment
it's the time when he punched out a
celestial dragon prejudice is quite the
sensitive topic
and it should come as no surprise that
anime would be one of the mediums to
show us and teach us about quite the
relevant topic
in this situation it's one piece
showcasing how much people look down on
races
such as the fishmen the celestial
dragons particularly charlos
are not a pleasant bunch of people and
this episode more than highlights what a
nasty group they could be
charlos is already quite the unlikable
character but he decides to take it a
step further the breaking point is when
he just
outright shoots hachi thankfully luffy
is there to exact revenge for the fish
man
and he does so in the most impactful way
possible by punching out the noble
no hesitations no questions asked it's a
blow that sends shock waves across the
seven seas
both in and out of universe can't say
that charlos didn't deserve it though
he deserved every little bit
attack on titan showed us a master class
on titan slaying and who better to show
us than humanity's strongest soldier
himself
[Applause]
i don't know that stomps can be this
satisfying attack on titan being the
amazing show that it is
managed to do it i think that context
plays a big part here but as a
standalone
fight which i say in air quotes this
moment still feels amazing i've never
been this excited to see a titan get
destroyed
and that's definitely saying something
perhaps what built up this moment being
so gratifying
is the sacrifices that were made
beforehand rousing speeches
glorious charges or to set up levi's
one-on-one meeting with the beast
titan levi grabbed the baton pass to him
and finished with flying colours
methodically cutting down and dicing the
beast titan from all sides and angles it
was truly a masterclass of unprecedented
magnitude
i don't think that anyone was as badass
as levi fighting the beast titan and
all of the context behind the moment
probably makes this one of the best
attack on titan episodes
not just in the season but in the series
as a whole
[Music]
oh
great anime characters are forever
immortalized by trademark moments that
everyone will remember them by in a
great series like full metal alchemist
the major characters all get their time
to shine that goes from the elric
brothers
scar and all the way to the more minor
supporting characters
roy mustang is no minor supporting
character but he just has so many of the
cool moments if i were to pick
one of them i'd argue that the fight
against envy is the best and by far the
most satisfying one
anyway to cut the story short having his
disguise blown while confronting riza
envy simply gets destroyed by the real
mustang it's not actually the fight
itself that's so satisfying but the
vindication after the reveal that took
place beforehand about mv's role
in the death of maize hughes i call this
a fight versus envy but let's be real
this is a slow and methodical execution
more than anything else
you can feel the intensity of the
aggressive finger snapping with each
second and is something so fulfilling
i've seen mustang be cool in a lot of
instances but this has got to be one of
the best among such moments
[Music]
is there a moment more epic and
satisfying than gone's beatdown on beto
yep that's a rhetorical question but for
me it's the undisputed most satisfying
moment in the whole of hunter hunter
imagine something like the garneke
moment where the normally nice guy gets
pushed to the limit and just snaps but
taken way over the limit this time you
know i have goosebumps just thinking
about that moment right now when you see
gohan's appearance
the overall acting and the whole
atmosphere in the scene it's just
surreal
the resulting beatdown is probably not
the best anime fight ever but when it
comes to evoking emotions this is one of
the examples that showcase what peak
anime could be
this is truly an amazing moment that
furthers gone's character development
and gave us a scene to remember while
doing it it's not every day that you can
see the role of hero and villain look as
if they swapped for the first time and
look so powerful
for that this moment tops our list
that's it for our list today the top 10
moments that just feel satisfying and
gratifying in anime
what about you what moments gave you
that adrenaline rush out of fulfillment
i'd love to hear your thoughts so make
sure to take your time to type your
comments down below before leaving
don't forget to hit both the like and
the subscribe buttons also feel free to
check out my patreon if you have time as
well i'll surely be able to take this
channel to new heights
and give you even more anime content in
the days to come i've left a link below
so come drop by if you'd like to support
the channel this will have to do it for
now and i'll be seeing you next time
thanks for watching
and hope to see you again soon
[Music]
you